Hey, we have our special guest back with
us. Professor Ciang, Beijing based
educator, writer, and advocate for
education reform. Known for his work in
promoting creativity, crit critical
thinking, and global citizenship in
Chinese schools. He gained international
attention in 24 for his viral
predictions about geopolitics,
foreseeing Donald Trump's return to
power, US Iran conflict, and US losing
that war based on historical patterns
and game theory. Welcome back to the
show, Professor Jen. Good to see you.
>> Thanks, Jimmy. Thanks for inviting me
back.
>> Now, the first thing I wanted to bring
up, this happened. So, I don't know if
you're up to on this, but the United
States has attacked a ship, right? So
they they're going to block the straight
of four moose and uh here let me just
play this is what Scott uh Ritter this
is his assessment of what happened and
I'll get your re response
hang on
>> civilians.
Well, my understanding is that the um
there was a Iranian cargo ship was uh
making transit out of the straight Omuz
into the um the u Gulf there and uh in
accordance with the agreement that was
reached between the United States and
Iran and uh Islamabad about the the
ceasefire um and an illegal American
blockade. It has no legitimacy under
international law and is a complete
violation of the ceasefire agreement. Um
demanded that the ship stop, the ship
didn't and the United States uh the US
Navy vessel destroyer um told the uh the
ship to evacuate the engine room. Then
they fired on the engine room um causing
the ship to come to a halt. Then US
Marine raiding group was landed on the
vessel and took control of the vessel.
It is an act of piracy. There's no
legitimacy for uh for this action
whatsoever.
>> Well, what would be the goal of
something like this? Why would Trump and
Hegath even order this?
>> It's pure psychological operation. This
is about the United States spinning um
the events so that the president can
claim that he has the upper hand that uh
you know if for instance Iran were to go
to Islamabad and agree to a deal. The
president would say it's only because of
his the strong stance that he's taken in
enforcing this blockade and compelling
the Iranians to you know see the common
sense and coming to an agreement. That's
all this is. It has nothing to do with
you know legitimately stopping uh flow.
Even even let's just say that let's just
acknowledge that this is an illeal act
uh like much of what the United States
does, you know, but the the goal is to
effectively halt shipping out of um the
straight of war moves by the Iranians
and this this most certainly is not
doing that. So um it it's just pure
theater of the absurd.
>> So uh what what is your response to the
act and his assessment?
>> Yeah, I completely agree. So a naval
blockade is considered an act of war and
so it uh it u breaks the spirit of a
ceasefire. Uh that's point number one.
Uh, point number two is that um I think
Scott Ritter is right in that Trump is
trying to negotiate from a a position of
strength, but I think the more obvious
explanation is that Trump and Hexep are
not serious about peace at all. Um, even
though um there is a ceasefire, we are
seeing a massive military buildup in the
Middle East. Uh when the George HW Bush
arrives in theater, possibly by Friday,
uh the Americans will have about 600
60,000 troops ready to go for a massive
uh invasion of of Iran, which is what a
lot of people expect to happen. So this
ceasefire, it's pure theater. It's just
a pretext to build up forces in the
Middle East.
And so
Trump I announced today
um that on Wednesday the ceasefire will
end. So that means he's going to start
bombing again. They're going to start um
what what do you what do you see
happening on Wednesday?
>> So um the ceasefire does expire on
Wednesday. that that that doesn't
necessarily mean that the bombing will
start right away because remember uh the
Americans need to get forces in
position. They need to stage the forces
and so it's possible that on Wednesday
Trump announces another two week
ceasefire and he doesn't really care
what the Iranians say um because they
need time to prepare for the strike. So
the Americans use something called shock
and all. So they want to go in, destroy
as much as they can, and then leave with
minimal um civilian casualties. So um
they are looking to uh strike as hard as
possible when the time is appropriate.
So, uh, let me just play you one more
clip from, uh, Scott Ritter saying that
if the United States does attack again
because they're stuck in a the United
States, Trump cannot escalate anymore
without having severe consequences rain
down upon the Gulf States, right? And
so, if Trump it looks like they're Does
it look like to you they're getting
ready for a grant a ground invasion?
They've got what 50 60,000 troops there
now. What What do you think they're
getting ready to do?
>> So, uh, from a military perspective, if
the wars escalate, then Americans in
round two will will use a three-prong
approach. Okay? So, the first approach
will be to try to economically strangle
Iran. So, the naval blockade will be
part of that, but the Americans will
also try to siege Car Island. They will
try to seize the Iranian coastline. And
so what the Americans are trying to do
is dislodge Iran from the sh of Humus
because right now the Iranians can
collect um tolls off the sh of Hummus.
They can export oil from Car Island. And
so the Americans want to blockade and
contain Iran. That's the first pillar.
The second pillar is to stir up ethnic
tensions in uh Iran. And the way you do
that is you establish for operating
bases in uh ethnic regions like Bakistan
and the Kurdish region. And then you
encourage and you arm ethnic insurgents
against against the um government in in
Iran. And the third thing which I think
will be the most effective is you will
start you will start to suffocate Tran
the capital. You do that by limiting
their capacity to access food, water,
electricity. You basically bomb power
plants, you bomb reservoirs and you you
bomb railways. And so you force the
population into submission. And for and
if you do these three strategies, the
theory is that you will force Iran into
a political settlement.
>> And what what kind of settlement do they
want? I mean, it it it seems what what
do you what does has Trump even said
what he wants? He said he he wanted he
said he wanted complete um victory or a
complete surrender. But what does that
what does that mean?
>> What it means is that the Americans can
impose terms. So what this means is that
the Iranians the Iranians will have to
surrender their uranium all their
Iranian. They will have to surrender the
ballistic weapons program. They will
have to abandon the proxies and they
will have to uh install the shaw um as
their new leader American puppet. So
that those are the four conditions for
surrender.
>> Oh that really okay. Do and what do you
think the likelihood of that is?
>> 0%.
>> Zero, right? Yeah, that seems crazy. So,
so be so it seems like for for real
they're going to
again ask try to uh resume the war the
that Donald Trump and the United States
is going to resume the war either
Wednesday or after another phony
ceasefire giving them time to I mean
Iran sees what they're doing. They see
that they're bringing they know what's
coming. And so here's what uh Scott
Ritter had to say will happen once the
United States starts the war again. And
I want to get your reaction to it.
>> Well, the Iranians have made it clear
that um they're not going to, you know,
start slow and finish fast. They're not
going to wait for the United States and
Israel to set the pace. Um which is what
they did in the 40 days. The the
escalation, the nature of targets, etc.
uh that were you know engaged by Iran
were largely defined by the nature of
the Israeli American strikes against
Iran. Um here the Iranians I believe
will start with the notion that uh
because the United States is incapable
of negotiating good faith that you must
assume that any military action that's
now taken is done to uh eliminate the
regime of u of the um you know Islamic
Republic and um therefore this is an
existential war. therefore um just go
for the juggler from the start. And I
think this is what you're going to see
if we start attacking Iran. I think
you're going to see Iran hit some Gulf
Arab states harder than they've ever
been hit. Hit Israel very hard, start
taking out key infrastructure, and um
you know, maybe reach out and touch the
United States in a few places as well.
Um you know, that that the United States
has grown overconfident in terms of
operation. But um you know, this is
going to be a one-way street. When the
war starts, we will be bombing empty
buildings. absolutely blowing up bridges
and railroad tracks that have no
fundamental value from a military
standpoint. Um and Iran is going to be
you know striking back with um absolute
devastation. Uh
and the the defeat will be obvious after
the first three days when as I said u
perhaps Abu Dhabi, Dubai, maybe another
city will be unable to sustain life on
the scope and scale necessary to be uh
to to retain the stature that they enjoy
today. uh people will be forced to
leave, flee by the hundreds of
thousands.
>> So, do you agree with that assessment? I
that's what we've been saying here all
along uh that if Trump escalates uh or
resumes this war that they're going they
have the ability to knock out the Gulf
States desaliniz desalination plants and
then that's game over for them. What do
you say?
>> I completely agree. So, um the most
obvious thing that uh the Iranians can
do is close off the Red Sea. Um and then
they they can strike at uh Gulf energy
infrastructure. They can destroy the
pipelines. This will knock out onethird
of the world's uh energy supply. Uh this
would completely destroy the Gulf
States. They were no longer viable. But
the problem is that the Americans have
made a calculation that this is an
acceptable cost that they are willing to
take the risk. And the reason why is
that in January, the Trump White House
um announced something called the
National Security Strategy. And so this
is the Pentagon strategy moving forward
for the next 5 to 10 years. And that's
four major pillars that help help us
explain why the war is progressing the
way it is in the Middle East. The first
major pillar is to secure the Western
Hemisphere, the American home front. The
second pillar is to contain China. The
third pillar is to make better use of
American allies to um basically
encourage them to participate more in
global defense. The fourth pillar is to
um ramp up America's wartime industrial
production. Okay. And we're always we're
already seeing these four pillars play
out. So from an American perspective,
the goal is to create greater North
America um something called a technate
uh fortress America. And then this will
become a self-sufficient
um perimeter that allows America to sell
resources, weapons, and financing to the
rest of the world. And what America will
do is create balance of power in each
different region. So in East Asia, Japan
and China will balance each other out
and they will both become dependent on
American armaments, uh, American
resources and American financing. Same
thing will happen in Europe where Russia
and Europe NATO will balance each each
other out and both will become dependent
again on America. And in East Asia um,
sorry, in West Asia, it will be it will
be the Gulf States and Israel versus
Iran. And this is the this is what's
laid out in national security strategy.
And unfortunately what we're seeing is
the strategy being played out in real
time.
>> So
what what why would why why would China,
Japan, Russia, what's their move? I
don't I can't see them just letting this
happen. Can you?
>> Right. So there's only one actual
response to America's national security
strategy. It is for Russia, Iran and
China to work together to create a
continental trade block uh that can then
absorb uh Africa, the Middle East and
Europe and East Asia and sort of negate
American naval power. That's why this
war in Iran is happening because um Iran
is really the pivot. It is where
Russia's north south trade quarter runs
through. It is where Europe's IMAC
quarter runs through. It is where
China's belit in initiative runs
through. So if you can create chaos in
Iran, the world is no longer able to
trade uh in Eurasia. It it's completely
dependent on on sea for trade and it
needs energy, right? So basically what
America is trying to do is create as
much chaos around the world as possible
so that the nations are dependent on
American energy.
And I again so what do you I mean Russia
is very oil rich and u they have what
what do you think
what will they do I mean
they'll they'll so tell me I mean I'm
like like in materially what will they
do
>> right so what's happening right now is
that the Americans are imposing a naval
blockade on all o on all ocean trade
right so we're seeing seeing um as you
mentioned this Iranian ship returning
from China being boarded being basically
being like seized and kidnapped by the
Americans. We're also seeing Russian
shuttle tankers being boarded by the
Americans as well. Um we're also seeing
this past month oil refineries fires all
around the world. So most famous um case
was in Geon Australia where a refinery
was suspiciously uh and accidentally uh
um on fire destroying Australia's access
to jet fuel. We're also seeing fires in
Bucharest Russia sorry Bucharest Romania
in India in Myar. We're also seeing the
Ukrainians start to strike uh Russian
energy infrastructure. So what what's
happening right now is basically a war
over uh energy uh resources between
Russia and America. And we we will see
this war expand over the next few years
as Russia challenges American dominance
in the seas and as both continue to
destroy each other's uh energy
resources.
>> So this this is really going to be world
war II and it's going to be for a while.
It's not. It's And
so this so you know the it's very
popular to say that the United States
did this war because Donald Trump is um
controlled by Benjamin Netanyahu, the
Zionists in Israel. But the way I hear
you explaining it now, it seems like
some kind of bigger long game that the
United States is playing for. We've
talked about the greater North American
project here and are uh is so was that
just kind of a diversion that to blame
it on Israel or is that real or has have
the has the establishment been planning
this all along and Donald Trump is just
their tool?
>> So first point is that if you don't
believe anything I say then I then go to
the the um Pentagon website, the front
of war website and download the national
security strategy. It is in black and
white. It tells you exactly what the
plan is. It is to contain China. It is
to um control the western hemisphere.
Something called the Don Ro doctrine.
And it is to cannibalize uh America's
allies. Okay, it's very black and white
in that paper. That's the first point.
Second point is that um Trump doesn't
have the power to do whatever he wants.
I mean, he is really the agent or the
puppet or the scapegoat for the
military-industrial complex. Um and the
third point I will make is that if you
just look at history when empires
decline they behave in this manner where
the empire uh at its height it rely
relies on consent. It relies on soft
power. When it declines and its allies
turn away from uh the empire what the
empire does is use force, use piracy,
use pure power. Might becomes right. Um,
so what America is doing right now fits
into the classical imperial decline
pattern.
So, okay. And so I mean you said that u
the United States was going to lose this
war or get stuck in in a quagmire.
Um, do you see this working out? Do
where do you see this heading in the
next 3 to six months?
>> Right. So again, if you look at like
history, these things never work out
because there are three problems with
this plan. It sounds great on paper,
right? Where America um controls the
Western Hemisphere, it has all the
resources of the world. It's
self-sufficient. The rest of the world
is at war and needs to buy American
weapons and resources. But if you look
at history, it doesn't really work out
for three reasons. The first major
reason is corruption. Okay? So America
right now is a very corrupt uh system.
And we know because um when whenever
Trump makes an announcement, someone
with impeccable timing is able to short
the market and make hundreds of millions
of dollars, right? So when um when when
Trump announced a ceasefire um then
someone buys shorts and makes a lot of
money off of the oil market. So this
this has been happening a lot, but
really the problem in America is the
financialization of the system. And so
people make their money not making
things but by on speculation. And this
is a this is a um a pretty common theme
in American um political system right
now. So you know Trump has announced
$1.5 trillion for the Pentagon and you
said this on your show but most of this
money is going to go into corruption.
It's going to be stolen. It's uh it
won't actually go into weapons
production. So that's the first problem
the corruption. Second problem is
political polarization. So when empires
are in decline, they usually split up
into different factions that fight um um
that fight each other. They really don't
care about the consequences for
America's position in the world stage.
All they are concerned about are
domestic politics. So even though
America's at war in Iran, the Democrats
continue to snipe at at Trump. Uh and
Trump's continue to snipe at at
Democrats. So Trump is much more
concerned about the Democrats than he is
about winning this war in Iran. So
political polarization is a huge problem
in America and it could possibly lead to
a civil war. Um that's the second
problem. And the third problem is
nationalism. When you bully nations like
what America is doing right now to the
Europeans, right? So Trump says that
he's going to take over Greenland, which
which has really annoyed the Europeans.
he's disgusting over Mexico, um Canada.
Um so what this does is that it um it
ganizes the people. It makes them much
more nationalistic. And we can see this
and we'll we'll see this happen over the
next few years as the the Americans
demand more of the North of the South
Koreans, of the Japanese. And this will
make them much much more more
nationalistic, much more anti-American.
Same thing will happen in Europe as
well. So these three factors corruption
uh division and nationalism ultimately
means that the empire will die at the
end of the day.
>> Do do you have a timeline on that? So
the so you know I was before uh this
Iranian war I was just worried about the
world stop using the dollar as the
reserve currency. That was my big worry
and I was just worried about how quickly
that was going to happen which is why I
we've talked so much about investing in
gold and stuff on this show because when
the rest of the world stops using the
dollar that it's horrible for for the
United States I mean and and us and our
retirement savings and everything which
is tied up in dollars. Um, so you're
talking about what is the end of the So,
so you keep saying this isn't going to
work out, right? You you've already
delineated the problems with this
working. It sounds like a great idea. I
hear people say it talk about it, but
it's you it's not going to work. So,
where does that where do you see the
United States and say like five years?
>> Sure. So um there's actually a three
stage uh process when empires decline.
Okay. So in the first stage the empire
lashes out um um and forces it kind of
cannibalizes vasiliz it allies. Okay.
And in the first stage things look
great. The US dollar s uh soarses the
American economy uh soarses because the
world is dependent on LNG from the
United States. The reality is that it's
possible that Trump goes to China in
midMay and they sign a deal in which
China is buying more LNG from America in
which case Trump's going to look like a
political genius, right? Because he's
attacking Iran. He's managed to uh
humble China. So in the in the short
term things look great for the empire
because the world is completely
dependent on uh American resources
especially energy LNG. So that's the
first stage. But in the second stage,
>> can I stop you there? Can I stop you?
Sure.
>> The problem is that that plays right
into the way American businessmen and
our economy thinks. We think in
short-term quarterly profits. We don't
build for the long term. And so Trump
probably doesn't care. He'll like look
it'll it'll make the the next two or
three the last two years of my
presidency look like a victory and I I
exit I'm 82 years old as a victor.
Right. Is that that's right?
>> That's exactly correct. That's exactly
the problem. He's only thinking for the
next two three years which are gonna be
great for America but then you but then
afterwards what happens afterward what
happens is that you are u overleveraged
your your empire is um overextended
you're forced to call a national draft
in order to supply the ken fodder for
your uh empire your economy is
overheated it's it becomes a huge ponty
scheme um and slowly the rest of the
world recognizes that we need we need to
we need to unite against America if we
are to survive. And in the third stage,
the world goes to war against America on
multiple fronts. The economic front, the
diplomatic front, the military front.
And then America recognizes that it
cannot actually sustain its empire. It's
empire declines and dies.
>> And and so that when the empire dies,
that means for sure civil war, right, in
the United States.
>> Exactly. Exactly. For sure. Exactly.
>> And then we'll we'd have to create a new
government, create a new constitution
and all that stuff, right? Well, we
started from scratch. Is that how it
works?
>> Um, so
um if you just look at America as an
empire, it is most equivalent to Rome.
And when Rome started its civil war
process, it never really stopped its
civil wars. I mean, you might have an
emperor emerge and create a 20-year
peace. Um, but then when he dies, the
civil war starts starts again. And um
the so the reason why America may fall
into a civil war trap where it is
continuous civil war is that America has
no peer competitor in the western
hemisphere
and as a result all the conflicts are in
internal not external right so um an
empire when it falls it's it fights
civil wars but when it's threatened by
an external enemy it it it unifies um
against it foe But America doesn't have
a foe. It doesn't have a competitor. So
America could actually descend into
hundreds of years of civil war.
and and so okay so you you your
prediction is that in the next few years
this will look like a brilliant plan to
certain people because the dollar will
sore and China's going to be buying more
of our liquid uh gas and u
>> but that how soon does that end and it
starts to go the other way
>> um right so I I think it's entirely
possible that if Trump pulls us off and
uh he succeeds he might get a third
term. Um and so I think you know for the
next two to three years um this plan
will look really really strategic and
genius but again this is how all how all
how all empires behave when they
decline. So uh this is a natural
process.
Um, so,
so you say we're not going to break off
into civil war and fragmentation
for at least an not what, five years,
10,
>> right? Yeah. So, I think the civil war
the process begins if Trump gets his
third term, right? So, I say a Trump
third term because if you want to carry
this plan out to fruition, uh, you need
a pretty stable continuity of agenda,
right? Right? So it's entirely possible
that if Trump leaves office in 2028, the
Dem Democrats come to power and they
change this plan which would create
complete chaos. Um so you need a
continuive agenda. You need basically a
monarch in place in order to implement
the strategy. Um and if that were the
case, this would cause create a
constitutional crisis and this would be
the basis for a civil war. So if you see
this coming
um so clearly and history says this is
what's coming, the people in Europe must
know it's coming. But why do you think
they they're not reacting in the way a
rational
uh government would react knowing this
is coming? They seem to be almost in a
sense going along with Trump. They're
now doubling down on their war with
Russia for for for who knows why. what
what what what why is what what's what's
Europe's role in all this and why are
they doing it like they're doing
>> right so another characteristic of an
empire decline is the over
bureaucratization of society and what
this leads to over what the over
bureaucratization sorry the
bureaucratization of society democracy
right you you create
>> bureaucratization is that sorry yeah
sorry you you create an imperial
bureaucracy that becomes a bubble onto
itself right so if you go to Washington
DC I'm you've been Washington DC, it's a
bubble, right? It's the richest place in
the world. They could care less about
what happens uh in the rest of America
and in the rest of the world. Same thing
in a Europe where you have an improper
bureaucracy in Brussels. So people in
Brussels just care about collecting
their paycheck, collecting a pension,
and they they want to just keep their
jobs and so they're going to go with
with the flow and they become completely
divorced from reality, right? That's why
you've you've seen in these past 10
years this massive surge of immigration
into Europe even though Europe itself
cannot um sustain this immigration and
the response to criticism is to silence
critics right so in Europe um if you're
a criminal you're much more you're much
less likely to get visited by the police
than if you criticize the rise of crime
on social media right so if you um make
it a criticism on social media, you're
much more likely to visit get visited by
the police than if you actually commit a
real crime. So that so Europe is uh I
think it's basically become a dumpster
fire. Um it's a much more advanced stage
of decline than than America.
So basically just
you know people looking out for again
short-term thinking people looking out
for their own self-interest not their
country's interests not the long-term
interests and
uh and so is is it the is it the
strength of the milit the the the
international military-industrial
complex that uh that they they get more
and they're doubling down on the war in
Ukraine. They're doubling down on is is
that just what it is? And
>> yes.
>> Okay. And and so
>> because you know Julian Assange said it
best, the point is not to have
successful wars. The point is have never
ending wars because what wars do is they
transfer taxpayer money into the pockets
of a transnational elite. And that's a
very that's the point of war today. It's
not to win wars, it's to have wars.
I it's just
I mean I'm I still can't I'm you know
I'm I'm
kind of shocked right that there isn't
some you know there's no sober voices
inside the United you know there's like
maybe Thomas Massie maybe Ran Paul but
there's no like group of people that
it's all just I and I've been I guess I
shouldn't be surprised because I've been
saying it for years now that the United
States is not just a little corrupt up.
Like Joe Biden gives his kid a no-show
job and Trump gives his kid a deal with
Saudi Arabia, but it's 100% corrupt.
Like they're all corrupt. No, when they
get a session of Congress, they're not
there doing the bidding. I've said this
a million times. They're not doing the
bidding of students or workers or the
elderly or trying to fix the inf they're
there just doing the bidding. How can we
extract wealth from the taxpayers and
put it into the pockets of the people
you just described, the the the the WF
international elite, the globalists? And
that's that's what's so I guess I
shouldn't be surprised, right? I guess
is what I'm saying,
>> right? So, another uh issue that people
don't really discuss is the aging
problem in America where the leadership
in Washington DC have aged um a great a
great deal, right? The baby boomers are
still in in um in control. Think of how
many presidents are baby were baby
boomers, right? You had um Bill Clinton,
uh George W. Bush, Obama, uh Biden. I
mean like Trump, I mean I mean the baby
boomers have happened in in command for
a long long time. What we know is that
when a population ages, the elite, they
become much more authoritarian, right?
So if you're if you're an old person,
you're in your 80s, what you care about
is living for as long as possible. You
care a lot about germs. You care about
uh keeping keeping the streets clean and
that and so you you you basically want a
more authoritarian society. And that's
why I think a lot of young people today
are are so um um pessimistic about the
future.
>> Uh do you put any credence? So
there's there's a there you know there's
a lot of uh theories out there that CO
was a depopulation agenda because the
international uh bankers and the WF
types they realized that they can't
sustain the the the aging populations
and so they they did this vax uh which
has uh it's completely toxic and it had
the negative it has negative efficacy
And uh they had to rig all the numbers
in the systems. Like for instance, they
didn't if you died within 14 days of
getting your vax. They considered you
unvaccinated even though it's it there
there could be a correlation between you
dying from the vax. So that they had to
do all that. So do you do you put any
credence into that theory that there is
this uh kind of because it was a global
phenomena that they it wasn't just the
United States. It was everywhere except
for maybe Africa. Um, so do you do you
think that that there's any credence to
that idea that the the people in con
control really the handful of
billionaires that run the world really
did want a depopulation agenda?
>> Um, if that that were their plan, I'd be
very impressed. Um, I don't think
they're that smart and I don't think
they're that strategic. Um, I think that
CO happened because the baby boomers
were are really afraid of germs and
that's why you have these these uh
global lockdowns because the baby
boomers insisted on um on um on on
everyone sitting at home. So the best
the nation that best responded to COVID
was Sweden because the ep eptoologist
in Sweden said that you can't stop a
virus. It's impossible. So what? So
we're not going to disrupt the economy.
We're not we're not going to disrupt
schooling, but we will protect our
vulnerable people, which includes people
with diseases, which includes the
elderly population,
>> which is basically the Bington
Declaration,
>> basically. Basically, and it worked very
well for Sweden. Their economy was not
as impacted as the rest of the world.
But having gotten away with COVID lock
with the CO lockdowns, we can expect
that the elite will use the strategy
again if crisis were to emerge. Right?
So they're oppos they're not strategic,
but they're opportunistic. They don't
think ahead, but they see the benefits
of certain strategies. So if this war
were to continue, you we can imagine
lockdowns because of the energy crisis.
>> Yes. So that's what I'm thinking. So
that's why they they'll be able to um
people have already talked about it that
there's going to be energy lockdowns and
that they're going to have uh
surveillance and they're going to let
you know how much energy you're allowed
to use and once you exceed that they're
going to cut you off. They're going to
stop your car. They're going to stop all
that kind and do you do you see that
happening?
>> Yes. It's it's all part of the plan,
right? The 108 calls for a technocracy.
What is what is a technocracy? A
government ruled by AI. That's why
America's building all these data
centers even though they cost a lot of
money they don't really actually make
turn any profit right so if you're if
you are a company like open AI like the
more subscribers you have the more money
you lose because it actually cost you
more money to have subscribers then you
can generate profit for them but you
have operation Stargate in place $500
billion to build data centers all all
across America so why would they do that
uh and the answer is the tenocracy the
answer is you eventually you're moving
towards an empire. uh you need to create
an AI surveillance state uh digital
currency digital a uh um ID uh and it's
and it it helps you do a national draft
helps you control the people it helps
you ration energy and food
and and
so how
there do you do you see a way to to to
turn this around or or is this already
this in the cards because history
dictates and and uh they've
is there is there I mean is could could
there be a charismatic leader who turns
this around for the but they would just
kill him right
yeah so um I don't think this plan will
work out because the empire isn't
decline they're desperate right so they
want a national draft they want a AI uh
control grid um this is all part of
their plan But the people in charge
aren't that bright and they're not that
effective. And I think this is all going
to blow up in their face because I think
the American people are much more
resilient, much more creative than they
believe. It's worked out in China. If
you come to China, I'll show you around.
We have AI surveillance. We have um AI
uh digital currency and digital um ID.
And it's worked out well in China. But
the Chinese people are a different
breed. The American people love freedom.
They love liberty. And I think I think
that Americans rather fight than
surrender their their liberty.
And so so now I now I'm hearing you say
another like so there is a chance that
the the American people because we do
value our freedom uh although you
couldn't tell you know half the country
certainly didn't during co uh they they
were willing to accept the every single
restriction on their freedom and
including uh you know fascist Nazilike
impositions of making people forcing
people to take experimental medical
treatments
Uh so you so you you think that that the
the answer to this lies in the mass of
people coming together.
>> So yeah, the lockdowns were bad in
America, but they're nowhere nowhere
near as bad as that in China or Canada,
right? In Canada they were the trucker
protest and these were just people who
wanted a meeting with Justin Trudeau
because they had questions about the
vaccine mandate and instead they were
debanked. If you if you actually gave a
dollar to the truckers, you also
debanked. So, so Canada is far more
authoritarian than uh the United States.
Uh in United States, if you didn't like
the vaccine mandates, you move somewhere
else. You move to a red state that
didn't have these vaccine mandates. You
couldn't do that in China. You couldn't
do that in Canada. You couldn't do that
in Europe. So, I think that that um
America is really the best hope for the
world. Unfortunately,
the people in charge, even though
they're not that strategic, even though
they're that that smart, they are pretty
evil. So we can imagine that they will
um uh promote false flag operations.
They will promote civil wars in order to
justify the use of a AI surveillance
state.
>> And so
so you see us you see our empire in
decline. It might work for in the next
couple of years. And when you say Trump
will get a third term, do you you mean
they'll amend the Constitution to make
that happen?
Right. So, I I actually don't know the
legal technicalities here, but what I do
understand is that there's actually
nothing in the Constitution that
prevents Trump from from running as a
vice president in 2028 and having his
son Don Jr. run at the top of the
ticket. And then when uh they win in
2028 by rigging the election, then uh
Trump can then Don Jr. can just abdicate
and and then Trump will will be the
president again for the next eight
years.
I never I never thought of that. Isn't
that funny? I never thought that he
would run as vice president. That seems
so sinister. Um
so you so you don't predict a collapse
like by the end of the 2026 or 27 or
even 28, but um do don't you do you
think that so we'll
we going we're moving into a multipolar
world then? Right. So the world right
now it's overleveraged. It's
overextended. We've mortgaged the uh
future in order to enjoy the present. An
example is that uh right now the
population of the earth is about 8
billion people. But that's being
supported by fertilizers, by oil, uh by
medicine. So if the world were to
deglobalize and deurbanize, then people
would lack access to fertilizers and
cheap energy. And this would mean that
we would see a steep population decline
over the next 10 years.
>> Okay. Yeah. I mean, I've I've seen
videos recently of, you know, people
from the Club of Rome talking about this
decades ago that we can't sustain we
could only sustain maybe one or two
billion people on this planet.
>> And
I just can't believe that like this. So,
how come this stuff doesn't get taught
in schools? So, how come people don't
talk about this in colleges? How come
it's taken uh Donald Donald Trump to
make this these kind of conversations
come to the surface? Do you have any
theory on that?
Well, I mean, schools, public schools
were created to brainwash you, to
indoctrinate you. I know because I've
worked in education reform for the past
20 years, so I know how screwed up the
the school system is. There's one word
you're not you're never allowed to say
in education reform. I've been to a lot
of education conferences around the
world and no one ever talks about the
elephant in the room which is the idea
of a meritocracy. Why is it that you
have a hierarchy in a school system
where if you're smart you're allowed to
go to a good school but if you're dumb
you're not allowed to go to school at
all. And the reason is control. The
reason is indoctrination. The people who
graduate from the Ivy League and I know
cuz I went to Yale are the biggest ass
kissers in the world. They're not
smarter than you. They're not better
than you. they just happen to stick up
to authority better than than you. And
that and that's just the nature of the
school system that we have today.
>> That is true. Uh I've Yes. I've noticed
the people they came from Ivy League
schools to Hollywood and they ex they uh
excel quickly and it's through ass
kissing. They know exactly how to do it.
They know exactly how who's asked to
kiss and it it it I've I've noticed it
in my own little corner of Hollywood. Um
>> sorry so J if you you you spend like
like a week at Yale going to classes
you'd be shocked
by the level of education at Yale and
Harvard. You'd be like oh my god these
are the smartest people in the world. Oh
my god this is the level of elite
education that we have today. You'd be
shocked.
>> Yeah. I mean, yeah. I mean, I, you know,
again, I I always claimed that, you
know, I was a C student. I was because I
wasn't interested in school at all. And
um but but yeah, when I meet these
people, they I'm not I'm not as
impressed as I should be. Uh that that's
that's for sure. and
um especially the
>> you know what what I admire about you
Jimmy is that even though you're a C
student you're still curious you're
open-minded
uh you appreciate debate you ask good
questions and that's that's a secret to
learning in life
>> aren't so I'm still can let me just
switch the subject just a little bit for
a second
I'm still shocked uh I'm I'm constantly
shocked I'll never stop being shocked at
the people who got everything wrong
during CO. Not only did they get it
wrong, but they tried to they embraced
authoritarianism to shut other people up
like me who were just asking questions
because I noticed something and I was
asking relevant questions that they were
afraid. So, they're not afraid. They're
afraid of the questions. And these
people still today will call ivormectin
horsepaste or they'll still swear by the
the vaccine. They'll still call people
antiax even even though we know what a
failure that COVID vaccine was. They
they still like as as if it's 5 years
ago. Uh and these are you know
relatively intelligent people in every
other way and they still it's like they
are going out of their way to stay
ignorant. And do have you noticed that
and what is go go?
>> Yes. Yes. I I I went to Yale so I I
encounter this all the time. Um but you
know 1950s C Mills wrote a book called
the power elite and he describes the
structure of power in America and he
makes a very interesting point in the
book which is like it's not the elite
the power elite that are most dedicated
to the system. It's the intellectual
class, the um um you know the the
chattering class, the professors, the
intellectuals, the the journalists who
are most dedicated to the system because
these are the parasites of the system
and they understand that they um their
power comes from the proximity to the
the elite and so they are the most vocal
about protecting uh the legitimacy of
the system as as well as the elite.
Okay. So these journalists, these
intellectuals, uh these professors,
these academics, they're most dedicated
to maintaining COVID because they
believe that by doing so, that's what
allows them to maintain their power.
Because think about what AI could do
with the coming of AI, the people um
these white color people are most at
risk, right? These lawyers, these
accountants, these teachers, because AI
can just do what what they do at at a
cheaper cheaper price. So need they need
to be able to justify their existence
you know their high their high salaries
their very um easy lifestyle where a
professor works like six months six
months of the year. They do that by
trying to impose authority on the common
mass and saying you know you see we are
useful because we can control the the
masses. But the reality is that with the
rise of social media with the rise of
shows like like yours they can no longer
do so. And that's why they're so
desperate. That's why they're so anxious
and that's why they're so authoritarian
today.
>> So it's um who was the Steph didn't we
have uh who was that female Chinese
author who wrote that 40page book and
she talked about this
>> uh I don't know if you're familiar with
her
>> talked about the the class the
professional class
>> she talked about the the professional
professional managerial class.
>> Yes. Exactly. Exactly.
>> And that's what you're talking about
right now. And she and she noticed the
exact same thing, right? Exactly. That
they became the And I like to call them,
you know, they're supposed to be
>> Katherine Lou.
>> Katherine Lou, that's who it was.
>> And
>> Yes. Yeah. Yes. Yes.
>> And so, you know, I I call them
illiberal. They talk about their
liberals, right? And they're supposed to
be a liberal and conservative. There is
no liberals anymore in the United
States. They're all the people who
consider themselves liberals don't
realize that they've become the most
illiberal people in in the world. And
that go ahead.
>> They're only interested in maintaining
their privileges. Right. Again, these
are people who don't really work. They
just spend all their time talking and
like uh projecting authority and they
have like the easiest life. They're
they're basically parasites and so they
need to maintain uh their existence.
They need they need to like um
legitimize their their lifestyle.
Well, I'll tell you, you know, speaking
to this point, so, you know, I've gotten
into Yungian psychology over the last
six years and, you know, it's completely
changed my life and outlook on things
completely. And I used to be an atheist
and now I understand that that was
incorrect. And
what I've done, so I uh once a week I
would talk to this uh Yungian
psychiatrist or a psychologist and um he
would help interpret my dreams and
because you need someone else to do that
for you and and um recently and so I
only would have an hour and we'd only
get through maybe one or two dreams and
I have lots of dreams. I have three or
four dreams a night, right? And so it
was and I can't afford to do more than
one session a week because they're
expens they they charge a lot of money.
And so uh what I've started to do
recently in the last few weeks is to use
Grock and I'll put in my dream and as
soon as I wake up I put it in Grock and
I say please use Yungian analysis and
tell me what this means and then I and
it it is unbelievable
unbelievable and it's on point and then
I'll I'll instead of using starting a
different thread I keep it in the sag do
these dreams go together and there and
Gro is showing showing me how a dream
from two weeks ago connects with a dream
I had last night and how all the ones in
and they connect all of the and that is
so much more uh uh conclusive or I don't
know um encompassing than I get from my
so I'm I'm experiencing this in my real
life like I don't know if I need my
yungian psychologist anymore because I'm
getting this done when in way better
time I get more time with it anyway and
it's much more encompassing and so would
that be that's what kind of what you're
talking about and what Katherine was
talking about right
>> yes I mean like we're seeing like the
collapse of the elite intellectual class
right so you look at the New York Times
like who reads New York Times nowadays
right it's these boomers that read reach
New York Times
>> Bill Maher reads
>> right so so all they do is is just
appeal to the boomer um class with these
talking points of empire
um and the rest rest the rest of the
population is turning off, right? So,
we're we're seeing a lot of desperation,
anxiety among the intellectual elite.
>> Um
where do you where do you see Israel
ending up?
>> Right. So, um Israel it has um it I mean
it's a crazy place, right? I mean like
they don't mind going to war with the
world because that's just part of their
esquetology. That that's they believe
that if they go to the to war with the
world and the Messiah will come and lead
them to victory. So um Israel has
descended into this fanatical religious
outlook and it's not going to get
better. It's it's just going to get
worse and worse. And we can see that
Israel will eventually draw Tur Turka
into this war. This will become a
regional configuration.
Um but at the same time, as long as the
United States supports Israel, then
Israel will continue to um dominate the
the Middle East. And if if the United
States were to lose this war, then
Sencom would be incorporated into the
Greater Israel Project. Um, so I think
that Israel will continue to rise.
>> Well, I I really don't see, you know,
when you say if the United States were
to lose this war,
um,
it it's it's
Iran is going to wipe out the Gulf
States if the United States continues
this war, which it looks like they're
going to. So, the Gulf States will be
like, how do they not I can see this.
How can they not see this? And why
aren't they taking steps to do anything
about it?
>> Well, because if you're um the UAE, uh
you are in a very tough pickle, right?
Because
um option one is that you want the
United States to leave the uh Middle
East, in which case Iran becomes a top
dog. And now you you have to pay um
reparations to Iran for the war because
the Americans destroyed a lot of
infrastructure. They killed the supreme
leader and the uh Iranians will want
about a trillion dollars in reparations
and they can't extract that from the
United States because United States is
out an ocean away but they can certainly
demand that of the UAE right so that's
what option one option two is you fight
this war to the bitter end because
there's a chance that the United States
defeats Iran in which case you can
continue to do what what you do which is
to be like you know this money money
larger operation for the world. Um, so
those are your two options. Um, and
they're not great options, but option
two has a, you know, option two, it's a
better pay payout than option one.
>> Like, like I I don't, let's say I was
the Saudi prince.
My big idea, I mean again C student
here, but I would get all the Gulf
states together and form an alliance
with China and Russia and Iran and that
that wouldn't that be and then you know
Europe would probably follow suit see
what's see which way the wind is blowing
I don't know is is that stupid of me to
say those things
>> right so the issue is that these Gulf
days are creation of empire
>> meaning that you know 50 60 years ago
these were not uh prosperous places and
because of the petro dollar uh because
America was willing to provide defense
to the GCC and because America um was
able to support the GCC economies they
prosper and they urbanize. So they're
essentially vassels of America. If
America were to leave uh the the Middle
East, then the the people would probably
uh rise up and and and overthrow the
elite because they are corrupt. Um they
are pretty evil people and they're
incompetent as well.
And
and so I get it that that even makes it
make more sense for them to try to get
rid of Israel, the United States, and
create an alliance with the other two
superpowers in the world being China and
Russia. And then of course, you know,
the strategic power which is Iran. I I
it just again I don't understand why
they they the end of the road is
obvious. Iran is going to wipe them out.
They're going to be wiped out, right? Am
I wrong about this? How how do they how
do they get through the next year?
>> So, there's a conspiracy theory that the
Saudi royal family are crypto Jews. Um
I'm not I'm not sure if you've come
across this theory. I haven't. Just 200.
>> Right. So 2003
uh the Americans went to Baghdad and
they took control of the government and
they had access to all of the
intelligence files of Saddam Hussein and
and the Saddam Hussein and his people
were absolutely convinced that the Saudi
royal family uh are crypto Jews. Okay,
so let me explain what I mean by that.
So the house of sod came to power
because of their alliance with with the
Wahhabi religious movement and both for
creation of the British Empire in order
to destabilize the Ottoman uh empire.
And at this time in history this this
like the 19th century early 20th century
the British were working very closely
with with people called the do in
government empire. The dome are
cryptojsws. These are followers of
sometime Zevi who declared himself the
Jewish Messiah in 1666
and on the surface they are they are
they believe in Islam but at home
secretly they still practice their
Jewish faith and these are called the
dome and these are the people who
sponsor the young Turk movement uh to
overthrow the Ottoman Empire and
establish the republic of Turkey. So
these are the people who run Turkey
today and a faction of them u worked
very closely with the British and the
British installed them throughout the
Gulf States including the UAE and
including Saudi Arabia. So so that's a
conspira theory. Okay, I don't have have
any evidence. Uh but that's what a lot
of people believe happened and that's
why the UAE and Saudi Arabia are so
close with Israel and that's why they're
so supportive of American Empire.
>> I Wow. No, I haven't. I haven't. Uh why
do they call them cryptojewe?
>> Because they are secretly Jews. They're
not like they they convert to
Christianity or Catholism or Islam on
the surface, right? They they on the
surface outside in public, they do
everything that um that a Muslim or a
Christian would do, but at home among
their circle, they still practice a
cabala.
>> Oh.
And so what what do you make? I I've
asserted this many times on the show
that the greatest trick the Zionists
have pulled off was to get Christians to
believe their number one enemy were
Muslims. Whereas the Muslim world
actually venerates Jesus, the mother
Mary as the opposite of what the Jewish
culture does. And would you agree with
that assessment?
>> I completely agree. So before the before
the creation of the state of Israel, the
Jews and the Muslims got along really
really well. In fact, the second largest
um Jewish population in the Middle East
outside of Israel is actually in Iran in
Tran.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, so the Muslims have made a
point of welcoming Jews uh because they
see Jews as a holy people along um and
and so in the year 1492
the Spaniards expelled the Jews from
Spain, right? And it was the Ottoman
Turks, the Ottoman Empire that sent
ships to help the Jews move to the
Ottoman Empire. So the Jews were
expelled from Christian Europe and they
moved to the Ottoman Empire where they
were welcome with open arms.
>> Okay. Um
so
>> and look look if you if you look at
these extreme Islamic movements uh
including ISIS, including the Wah the
Wahhabis, they were clearly creations of
the Anglo-American Empire.
>> Clearly,
>> right? You look at ISIS, they never
attacked Israel for whatever reason.
>> Clearly, right? They've got attacked
everywhere else in the Middle East, but
they never attacked Israel.
>> 100 I've been making that point uh for
quite a while now. Yes, that uh well,
look who's the head of Syria right now
installed by Israel and the United
States. It's the former head uh chief
head chopper of al-Qaeda and he he's
working handinhand with Benjamin
Netanyahu. In fact, he's publicly said
he wants to be in partnership with it.
It's just so it's just so obvious and
the you know the people in America are
such suckers and that uh you know it's
one thing to be suckered it's another
thing to keep being suckered and that
this it that the you know so and and it
just people you weren't allowed so again
the thing about when you're not allowed
to question something like you weren't
allowed to question 911 and now I know
that 911 was not what it seemed to be at
all. It was not what it it was the it
they needed a 9/11 so they could go and
do what they're doing and this was all
part of the greater Israel project. What
people don't realize is that as you
brought mentioned there's a greater
North America project and it's got a
technate state and we we've talked about
this on this.
So this all so the only way to kind of
save Western civil or the world right
now is for the American people to wake
up to this, right? And do you think they
will or what do you think? What what
does history tell us?
>> Um so the only hope for the world right
now is the American people. Uh because
the people in charge, the elite, they've
colonized so many different parts of the
world. Like China is a colony of of the
elite of of the national elite. People
don't recognize this, but China is very
subservient to the global elite. Um
Europe, Canada. Um so the best hope for
the world is the American people
recognize what's happening and they
resist. And quite honestly, there's one
movement in America right now that has
the most uh promise and that's MAGA.
Right? So if Carlson were to run for
president of the United States and MAGA
were to fully unify behind him, then I
think there's hope for the world.
>> Yeah, I would I don't know if I would
call it MAGA because the the the the
MAGA has been completely uh flipped on
what it was when Donald Trump became
president. It was it was made up of
people like Tucker Carlson and Candace
Owens and Dave Smith and and even Joe
Rogan and Theo and that's all gone. Now
it's all the people who were never MAGA
are now what Donald Trump refers to as
MAGA. So I wouldn't I would say the
former uh iteration of MAGA uh which
Tucker Carlson could very easily lead
and he's very good at um you know
bringing people together now which is
crazy. Um and and now you know looking
through the you know looking backwards
you see how he was demonized only when
he started to do the right thing that
the the establishment loved him. The
left always hated him because divide and
conquer is what the establishment does.
But um now now they he got in trouble uh
with his bosses when he started to see
through it and he saw through the you
you know the empire and he saw he saw
through uh the war machine and you can't
do that and that's why he's got he he
got kicked out of uh you know his
establishment position. Um, do you what
do you So, do you do you think that
that's Let's say Tucker Carlson ran for
president. Wouldn't they just kill him?
>> Um, you know, um I I I'm most impressed
with Tucker Carlson and uh not only do
do I think his heart is in the right
place, as you say, he's been the most
consistent anti-war voice in the
mainstream American media for the
longest time. Um, and that's very brave
of him. Um, but I also think he has a
very good read on the political winds in
America. He's also like an American
patriot. He loves America deeply in his
heart. Um, and so I think there are a
lot of people in Washington DC who
secretly support him, right? I mean,
like there I I I don't think that uh
everyone in Washington DC is corrupt and
willing to sell out. I I think there are
a lot of people in Washington DC who are
just hoping that a leader emerges that
can represent um the true America, the
true America who who who will restore
America to its former greatness. And um
and I I I would not be surprised that
there are a lot of people in the deep
state um itself who are very supportive
of um a resurgent America under to
Carson.
And so the
the the more I uh uh look at things, the
more I'm convinced that Donald Trump's
uh assassination attempts were faked and
they were inside jobs, especially
Butler, Pennsylvania. Uh and the and the
key piece of evidence is that Donald
Trump is not interested in who actually
tried to do that. The conspiracy behind
it, it's just a lone nut who was able to
somehow uh get through all
there. Why? Why aren't they watching the
roofs? Nobody's watching the roof at P
Butler, Pennsylvania, even though the
crowd saw him. Same thing with Charlie
Kirk. There's a roof. There's a guy on
the roof for at least a couple of
minutes with a rifle and nobody in the
security saw him. That's it's
impossible, right? Um so this do you do
you I I know. So, I am convinced uh that
Donald Trump was in on that uh that
Butler, Pennsylvania thing. And um what
do you think about it?
>> Well, it certainly helps us understand
why there's a disparity between the
first term and the second term, right?
So, in the first term, uh all of
Washington was unified against Trump.
They tried to sabotage him from day one,
right? With this Russia uh gate hoax, uh
the mainstream media was clearly against
uh Trump. So when Trump ordered the
American troops out of Syria, he was
just ignored by the military.
>> Yes.
>> Um you know, you you had the chairman of
the Joint Chief of Staff, Mark Millie,
call the Chinese and say, "Hey, don't
listen to what this guy says. We're in
charge." That's treason.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Um and and so in the first term,
there were a lot of leaks. There were a
lot of turnover. Uh in the second term,
you see a lot more discipline. You see
Trump actually carrying out a plan. And
so it's entirely possible that what
happened was that um at the end of at
the end of his first term the deep state
um there were many um political factions
that tried to destroy Trump once and for
all right so January 6 was clearly a
stage operation by the FBI in my opinion
>> clearly. And then after he left office,
there was the raid, the FBI raid on Mara
Lago. There's lawfare. They tried to
bankrupt him. They tried to put him in
prison. They tried to remove him from
the ballot box. And he was really in a
lot of trouble. So at that point, he had
no choice but to make a deal with the
deep state saying that, you know, look,
Biden is useless. Uh Putin's going to uh
control the world if we continue to have
Biden in the office, but Biden's not
going to like leave office voluntarily.
So like, let's make a deal. like we'll
we'll we'll allow you to go back into
office
um and but you have to promote our
agenda which is the uh American Empire
agenda and uh maybe Butler Pennsylvania
was a ritual in order to seal the deal
right because if you actually look at
the specifics of the assassination where
um Trump's ear was bleeding and he
didn't have a shoe that actually fits
into a biblical description
of like a um of a prophet or or a
messiah and it's in the Bible. I believe
it's in Leviticus, right? So, not only
was it staged, but it was staged as a
religious ritual in order to anoint
Trump to be uh the avatar or basically
the scapegoat for the deep state.
>> Same thing with Charlie Kirk's public
assassination. They had to do it
publicly, right? That was also some kind
of ritual killing. Correct.
>> Yes. Yes. That that that is correct.
Yes. Yeah. There there are a lot of
ritual aspects to to that to that
assassination.
>> And where do we where do these rituals
come from? Are you can you speak to it?
Um, so I don't know the specifics, but I
imagine these are free free Masonic
rituals um that involve the Cabala
um and they are are part of the free
Masonic mythology, right? So if you look
look at the JFK assassination, you look
at the Charlie Kirk assassination, these
are all come from a certain um uh
mythology in in the three mason world.
Yeah. Um, did did you hear about the so
Candace Owens has been
saying that the you know the Charlie
Kirk's assassination was a military
operation which it's clear that they
were certainly involved and the freak
out over her discovering the Fort Wuka
connection was again proof of this.
Um, and then did you hear that? Uh, so
they all there was maroon, lots of
single individuals wearing maroon at the
event with Charlie Kirk's assassination.
And then that's the color of the French
military. And then she's saying that
that there was a Masonic lodge of made
up of ex-French military that the French
government just recently charged them as
being an assassination ring. Did you
hear about that? And this fits into that
perfectly, right?
>> Yeah. So, this would not surprise me.
Um, also we have to remember like this
happened in Utah, which is where the
Mormons are. The Mormons are are very
important part of the deep state. So, so
this is probably an operation
>> that involved a lot of of different deep
state factions.
>> Yes. Coming. It wasn't just one. It
wasn't just the MSAD. It wasn't just the
CIA.
>> It wasn't just the French military. It
was the the Mormons. that all those and
all those people can and Donald Trump
and Dan Bonino and Cash Patel are
completely aware of of this happening
and they know that if they try to go
against it, they're going to end up like
Charlie Kirk themselves, right?
>> Yes. And um um we know what happened
after what after Charlie Kirk was
assassinated, right? There's there's no
any major opposition uh towards this war
in Iran,
>> right? He was the only one. I mean, he
well, he he was certainly the most
powerful one because he had a following
and he had all all the conservatives
under 30. So, they had to get rid of him
and that's definitely what
>> and he would not compromise on this
issue. He would not compromise on this
issue. I mean, he he went on on it for a
long long time, right? Uh starting with
the um with last year's uh 12-day war. I
mean, he went he went to White House and
talked to Trump directly and said, you
know, you got to stop this.
And do you think that's when the I think
that's when the decision was made to get
rid of him and they tried one more time
to bribe him in his meeting uh at the
Hamptons and he turned it down and that
was like they they had already the plan
was already in progress to kill him but
they were like well let's try one more
time and they it didn't work. he turned
down their money and you know of course
his uh and and and in retrospect his
wife Erica Kirk it's obvious she was put
in his life she was a she's her whole
life you know she's a 17-year-old beauty
queen somehow working with trafficking
in Romania just none of it and so you
know what I say is if the CIA had a
vagina she came out of it and um it and
everybody around him from Tyler co to uh
I mean Tyler Bowden to Andrew Co, Mikey
McCoy, his father, all those pastors.
It's a it's one big swamp, right? That's
the swamp.
>> Well, that's what the Epstein file
teaches us, right? I mean, these are
extremely depraved people.
And what do you by, by by the way, what
do you make of the jour journalists uh
who had really great reputations up
until the the
Epstein files and now it there seem to
be and it you know it's like whether
it's whether it's Epstein himself or uh
whether it's uh does Epstein dead or whe
whether it's the files uh you see people
like Michael Shelonburgger Matt Taibbe
Um, what do you what do you make what do
you make of that? Like them trying to
dismiss what everyone sees?
>> Yeah, I mean I've been a huge fan of
MTabies for the longest time, right?
Starting with the 2008 2008 great
financial crisis. He did amazing
reporting and Rolling Stone and I've
been following his work for the past
decade. I'm a huge admire of his work
>> and I don't I don't have any any clue as
to why he did what he did. Um, you know,
there are theories that the IRS visited
him and um, that might has have
something to do with it. But usually in
these cases, what happens is that you so
you associate a certain group of people,
they become your friends, you spend
weekends together, you go on cruises
together, your kids know each other, and
you just want to stay in that circle,
right? And stay in that circle just
means you have to conform to the talking
points.
>> And you think that's it?
That is a possibility. Um I think that
you and I are able to do what we do
because uh I imagine uh I I I don't know
about you, but um we are marginal we're
we're very much marginalized in society.
>> Yeah. To say the least. Yes. Certainly
on my part.
>> Very very marginalized. And uh I I got a
good taste of it during forced to vote
when I presented this idea that the
whole left is supposed to be rallying
around for decades, which they were. And
then as soon as it became a possibility,
they turned on me and they came at me as
hard as possible and tried to discredit
me, you know, in every every which way.
They still do it till today. And not
only that, but they got uh, you know,
useful idiots, people who I've known all
my life to go along with it, which and
and they got nothing out of it, right?
Which is except they just got
brainwashed and they were
>> Go ahead.
>> And you were completely vindicated on
force to vote. I mean, you're absolutely
right
>> because Republicans did the same thing,
right?
>> Say it again. Yeah. When the Republicans
had McCarthy wanting to be speaker, they
did exactly what we were advocating the
the squad to do for force to vote and it
worked like a charm for them. They got
everything they wanted.
>> Exactly. Exactly. So, it just shows you
what a fraud AOC is.
>> Yeah. 100%. But she's I you know I I
believe she'll probably be the nominee
or the vice presidential nominee going
in 2028. So, there's no there's no
voting our way out of this. I've known
this now for a while. And um and you say
that the you think that the original
MAGA coal coalition, the people like
Tucker Carlson, the Candace Owens, the
that if they can somehow find a way uh
to organize and come together, but
doesn't that involve you need labor,
right?
>> Uh what do you mean by by labor?
>> By you need unions.
>> Right. Um yes. Um, but unions have been
decimated in America, right? I mean,
like they're no longer as powerful as
they used to be. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. 100%. Less than 10% of the workers
are are in unions and most of them are
government union. We were government
workers. But Well, I you know, I said
like if the if the railroads uh that we
almost had a railroad strike here and
then Joe Biden and the Democrats
interceded to make it illegal for them
to go on strike and if they would have,
they would have won that strike
immediately. And it would have empowered
workers across the country which is why
they had to make it illegal. And so if
if you get so let's for instance if you
got the railroad workers to actually not
go to work that would that that would
capitalism in America if you got
the port workers to do the same. If you
got the the people who work at the
Amazon fulfillment centers or if you got
the UPS drivers uh if you got all even
like one of them but if you got them all
together that would be that would be it.
And that's how you have to take over the
country. That's what I think. You have
to stop capitalism and that's how you
gain power. It's kind of like Go ahead.
>> Sorry. Sorry. I you Yeah. I I didn't
think of this before, but you convinced
me. The key is labor, right? Because AI
can replace actually uh the white collar
class, teachers, professors,
accountants, lawyers, they can be
replaced actually pretty easily, but you
need labor. You need essential workers.
You you need people actually do the real
work. Uh and we know this from COVID,
right? where during co uh you know these
people still had to work but the uh
everyone else could just at home on
their lap and and just play on their
laptops. So I I mean you're absolutely
right. I I I think the key is is to
galvanize the the lab the labor
movement.
>> Um and you know of course they know how
they've infiltrated the labor movement.
So, just like everything else is
infiltrated, just like the Democratic
Party, the Green Party, the Republican
Party, uh the DSA, they're all
infiltrated by the deep state and
controlled and it's all divide and
conquer. And so, just like the unions,
so it's going to be very hard. Uh but
that's the only that's the only way we
can, you know, and the template is there
from the truckers, right? So, the
truckers did it on a even a a small
scale and it worked. if we could get
the, you know, uh the the AFL CIO, which
is the truck drivers, uh just them to do
it. Or if you just get the railroad
workers, or if you get them in
conjunction with the port workers,
that's it. Game over. We the people win.
And of course, they'll try to do things
like assassinations and again more
infiltrations, but that's the I to me
that, you know, because people like to
say this, they say this a lot. Uh you'll
hear people say, "Oh, we need a general
strike." Okay, that's a great idea. Stop
saying that. Right. uh say something,
you know, specific and constructive and
what I'm saying I think is actually more
specific and more constructive and
actually something more likely to work.
Um it it's it's Go ahead.
>> Yeah, the comment would be illegal
immigration, right? So you ask yourself
why the Democrats have let in, you know,
millions of illegal immigrants when
Biden was was in power. And it could be
a possibility. I mean like I'm
speculating but it's it's just to dilute
the power of labor of course in the
future.
>> Of course. No 100%. And to keep uh the
people from coming together to fight the
oligarchs. What they do then is you have
workers fighting people who are in a
more desperate situation than them. And
look at that. And and and the immigrants
who we overthrew their governments in
their country and made their life
unlivable who come here. So now we got
the people at the bottom fighting
instead of people at the bottom coming
together and fighting the people at the
top. And it works perfectly. It's
working, still working. People are
cheering on what ICE is doing across the
country. And again, we need to have
immigrate. We need to have a strong
border and all that stuff. But the
demonization of the per if I have always
said this, if you find yourself angry at
someone lower on the economic ladder
than you, it's a good chance you're
being manipulated by someone higher on
the economic ladder than you. It's
obvious. Yeah. And also we we have to
remember that ICE is also part of the
technate plan, right? Because you want
to create an AI surveillance state. So
you need an enforcement mechanism and
that that' be ICE. So what's happening
is that they're using illegal
immigration in order to normalize ICE on
the streets everywhere.
>> That's exactly. And so yeah, they don't
need $80 billion
uh to run an ICE an immigration program.
What they do is if you want to create
another uh authoritarian police state
and that that's that's what you would
do. And you're exactly right. And that's
what the the job of ICE there isn't
really immigration. It's there to
normalize this kind of authoritarian uh
takeover of our life, this technate
state. That's exactly what's happening.
All right. This is always uh good to
talk to you, but it's always so
depressing. Um uh but it's good. You get
you got to you've got to see it first.
You got to have the scales fall from
your eyes so then you know what to do
about it. Um let me um what give does
anything give you optimism and and what
offramps are there do you see for these
worse outcomes?
>> So you know people like like you people
like Ter Carlson Kenneth Owens give me
tremendous hope for the future because
you're still allowed to say what you
believe. You speak from the heart. You
have tremendous audiences. uh your
audiences love love you and um I I I you
you know this for yourself but your your
voice is resonating all across America
and the world. So that that's what gives
me gives me hope. The other thing that
gives me hope is that the people in
charge aren't that smart. They're not
that strategic. We shouldn't give that
give them too much credit. Uh they're
going to make a lot of mistakes. They're
going to miscalculate. They're too
arrogant. um they're going to create
opportunities for for other people. The
third thing I will say is that the elite
themselves are not unified. If they
were, they could just what do what they
want. There are different factions of
the elite fighting fighting fighting
among themselves. And so um this creates
opportunity for new political movements
um that could possibly galvanize labor
can can galvanize 99%.
>> Okay. Um, Professor Jiang, I really
appreciate uh your insight. I appreciate
you talking to me and and talking to our
audience. Uh, we can't get this kind of
information uh from the Wall Street
Journal, the New York Times, the
Washington Post or or MSNBC or Fox News.
They can't get it. We have to come here,
which is why they try to marginalize us
and try to take our advertising away.
And uh so I just really appreciate the h
what kind of so what uh what what's the
reaction to why do they allow why does
the Chinese government allow you to do
this?
>> Okay, that's a great question. So I'm
very much marginalized in China.
Everyone thinks I'm an idiot in China.
Um so um but because like the response
is just to just ignore someone if you
don't agree with that person, right? Um,
the other thing is that I only uh speak
in English to Western audiences. I don't
have a Chinese uh online media presence.
If I did, if I if I influential in
China, then the government would see me
as a problem. Um, and um yeah, so I I I
avoid u public appearances. I avoid
online media presence. I don't talk to
reporters in uh in in China.
>> Oh, okay. All right. So, uh, tell people
where where do you want people to to to
find you? You have a you have a YouTube
channel now that is blowing up, right?
>> Yeah. Right. So, thanks Jimmy so much
for um platforming me. Uh, I really
appreciate it. Um, I I love your show. I
love what you do. Um, I I love to talk
to you some more often whenever time
time permits. Uh, hopefully we we can
make this a monthly thing or something
because like I I I just love talking to
you. it it's like a kindred spirit and
and I I can say certain things on your
show I couldn't say anywhere else
because IBD platform but if if you want
to follow my work the best place is my
YouTube channel Predictive History um
and my Substack which is predictive
history substack.com.
>> Okay, fantastic. Uh I feel the same way.
I feel very kindred spirit and hopefully
we can uh we can share a meal and have a
conversation in person when I come to
China. I'm looking forward to
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. Absolutely.
We'll stay in touch.
>> Okay, we'll do. Thanks again. Hey, come
see us doing live shows May 7th in
Burbank, California. That's a Thursday,
May 16th, Tulsa, Oklahoma. Then we'll be
in Oklahoma City, Spokane, Washington,
and Tacoma. Go to jimmydor.com for a
link for tickets.